a huddle and they go no that wasn't it
that was terrible yeah i mean
and they'll look at back at it like why
don't we hire that guy or whatever
they say oh i hate that right so i go
with like a tom cruise blow up or do you
ever like really go for it
dude what do you think about his blow up
i respected it
he did it for you
literally like nobody has a blow up and
only positive [ __ ] ha
like but let me just we gotta save the
turtle
right like who gets angry and doesn't
curse
and just has positive things if he
dropped like an n-bomb in the middle of
it i'd be like okay this guy really
can't yeah yeah he just was the best guy
yeah like where we got to save people's
lives and their college education i have
a theory that i think that was a pr
move yes but but that's just because i
think that you know his stocks have
dropped
since the whole david miscavige thing
and he keeps doing these
big action movies but he's really kind
of out of the oscar contender kind of
so i think i think that was his attempt
to kind of uh galvanize support in the
industry and like make him look like a
good guy like he could because it worked
on me
exactly yeah because you really care
about corona i'm immune so i'm like you
[ __ ]
[ __ ] but
he he he used his power
and that's when you know he has power
because if i would have done it this
would this would have
happened this would have what happened
right hey guys i'm going to tell you
right now and then somebody would go
[ __ ] you and it's the [ __ ] gopher
[Laughter]
or the guy holding the boom boom [ __ ]
you sit down
[ __ ] yeah right and i'd be like oh
i'm sorry right
whereas they let tom go and i'm going to
say this
that last [ __ ] mission impossible
movie he did bomb
dude one of the best action moves i've
ever [ __ ] he's a beast he's a beast
he's a weirdo but he's a beast though
yeah that's the thing like if he was
funny
he'd probably be one of us like he's
weird enough to be one of us
he's just not funny no he but you know i
have to he was in tropic for thunder he
thought he was really acting
no but he was funny he was trying to be
funny i thought he was i think
they were like seriously be this we need
you to be that guy yeah yeah yeah
yeah he is a weirdo but you know what
dude it just just shows his power
yeah you know what i mean yeah you could
probably do that on your new netflix
show
damn right i could yeah is it a show or
a special what is it
i mean it's an hour special that we
broke up in four episodes so it's like
15 minutes each
right and they're it's what you were
doing on instagram instagram
literally yeah and then they they put it
on netflix yeah we just filmed like
longer versions of it
yeah i love how the last time you were
here we were talking so much [ __ ] about
netflix bro i had to
do it but now i know how it works
that's how it works how do you get laid